vous croyez vous êtes presse en chine a
annoncé trempé où cet appareil paris
13ème arrondissement dans les années 80
le quartier se trouvant sur noms
exotiques un china town à la française
s'est constituée sous nos yeux sans que
nous nous en apercevions un china town
avant tout habité par une communauté
vietnamienne des réfugiés du communisme
arrivé à la fin des années 70 rejoints
par des laotiens des cambodgiens puis
des chinois en 1981 ils sont estimés à
15000 nombre ils vivent dans ces tours
boudé par les parisiens parfois à 10 125
mètres carrés dans le xiiie
arrondissement
ils ont apporté leur culture leur mode
de vie les premiers arrivés gagnent leur
vie grâce à leur savoir faire
la couture et la restauration
en 1989 un habitant du 13ème
arrondissement sur quatre est d'origine
asiatique pour avoir voix au chapitre
cette même année il présente une liste
aux élections municipales
la liste europe nos compatriotes sont
restés très discrets sur leurs pensées
politiques
mais nous sommes la génération où il
faut bien un d-pad et nos pensées pour
que les français nous connaissent mieux
une liste non pas pour gagner mais pour
se faire entendre sur le plan politique
après s'être intégré dans la vie de tout
un quartier
année après année les asiatiques du
xiiie arrondissement en donner une
identité exotiques dans un coin de paris
que certains visiteurs recherchent tout
particulièrement
devant cette pâtisserie c'est une des
plus réputées du quartier chinois
à partir des années 90 alors que la
communauté grandit les asiatiques
s'installe à belleville aujourd'hui
deuxième plus grand quartier asiatique
dans la capitale
[Musique]